what's going on guys
Suicide Squad hitting theaters this week
it's about the worst of the worst
villains having a big old team-up well
in honor of that we decided to determine
who is the worst comic book movie
villain of all time
and by worst we mean crappiest we will
determine that right here right now and
we have an awesome panel of dudes to do
that with first you know he's a writer
for honest trailers and an all-around
swell guy Joestar oh he hasn't been with
us for a while but it's so great to have
him back he's a writer for @midnight
he's one of the co-hosts of the Jordan
Jessie go podcast Jordan Morris
hi al and I'd love to welcome back a
writer from geek and sundry and you also
know him from saving throw on Twitch sax
car guys I'm not gonna lie this is a
very complicated process but we wanted
to get it right we created eight
individual divisions one will move on
and then we will have eight villains
left over to whittle down to one the
villain to sit atop of the crappy shall
we dive in are you guys ready ready to
dive all right let's move into our first
division the Joel Schumacher Batman
division mr. freeze from Batman and
Robin poison ivy from Batman and Robin
Bane from Batman and Robin the Riddler
from Batman Forever and two-face from
Batman Forever I actually think we
should take Emma Thurman out of the
running because I think she is the only
one who's kind of good in that movie in
the same way that you can take Bane out
of the running because he's almost a
non-starter in that film I'm gonna argue
for Bane I like it because he's supposed
to be a he's supposed to be you know rip
it's just a fat guy it's like Bane is
not in good shape in that movie but I
still think that the like ice to me
juice warts and Egger character is so
bad he only spoke in puns he was like
doing a parody of himself allow me to
break the ice
I do like thinking about what would
happen if that movie was popular and
they just kept having to make mr. freeze
movies and him running out of puns like
I better get a snow job for this gotcha
so let's go mr. freeze yeah okay looks
like mr. freeze is moving on I think
it's worth mentioning that Tommy Lee
jones's two-faced was just ridiculous in
terrorem very bad hahaha
next up the Blue Man Group Ronan the
accuser from guardians of the galaxy
apocalypse from x-men apocalypse electro
from amazing spider-man 2 and the frost
giants from Thor boy these are some
these are some generic ass villains the
awesome by the book this is no thought
put into them villains I you know I kind
of like Ronan the accuser because I just
like that naming convention of someone
the something I think I think you're
right i think Ronan probably make sneaks
his way out of there I also think the
frost giants there they're not terrible
because we don't really know them very
well so it's got to be within the other
two I'm going with apocalypse from x-men
Apollo nothing was sadder than watching
Oscar Isaac try to act through a
California raisin costume for that
entire movie I'm giving it to him I
really really hated electro I think I
think it is a crazy I mean maybe not
when he's electro but when he's the nerd
character like Jamie Foxx Dylan Jamie
Foxx seems like the only nerd he's seen
is in Revenge of the Nerds birthday guys
we're locked up at 1 1 between
apocalypse and electro sacks your are
deciding vote uh kid should going based
entirely on when electro plays a techno
song on the like electro power grid that
he's taken over it's a lecture all the
way they ruined that character he was
terrible in that movie electro the worst
of the blooms when Oscar Isaac keeps his
reputation intact ooh
so electro is from a spider-man movie
but it was blue so he didn't make it
into our actual spider-man division the
Green Goblin from amazing spider-man to
evil Peter Parker from spider-man 3
the lizard from amazing spider-man venom
from spider-man 3 and Rhino from the
amazing spider-man 2 I think if you're
gonna if you're gonna hand someone a
victory based on the least amount of
screen time annoying the most movie
ruined the Rhino definitely takes his
category because I think he's only on
screen for a minute and it's at the end
of the movie but it's exactly where
anyone who was still on board like jumps
off yeah
I think the Rhino has this I think evil
Peter Parker My Chemical Romance
haircuts
jaunty strut down the street random
Tango scene yeah the dance sequence
acting on this as ridiculous as Topher
Grace as venom was and he was ridiculous
this camera
I gotta go with Taub evil Tobey Maguire
that in terms of only a little bit of
screen time and completely losing trust
like we working with Rhino I got to give
it to zoot suit Tobias evil Peter Parker
beats out the entire sinister six and he
is the worst spider-man villain of all
time we have reached ooh
the Superman division some call it the
Man of Steel division some called it's a
bird it's a plane it's a really ok Kevin
Spacey's Lex Luthor from Superman
Returns Jesse Eisenberg's Lex Luthor
from Batman V Superman evil Superman
from Superman three doomsday from Batman
V Superman and nuclear man from Superman
for the quest for peace I'm gonna say
nuclear man is off the table because
weirdly I think he's okay like I think
for a terrible character he kind of
plays into that movies energy in a way
that you don't hate it also sweet mullet
so he's got the mullet he's got the
fingernails he looks like he's like a
male model from the a it made from a
piece of Superman's hair being put in
the Sun we didn't know any better back
then those are simpler times doomsday
was made from Jesse Eisenberg's blood
and a pile of goop I I'm going I'm going
The Hobbit cave troll I'm going doomsday
okay that's one for doomsday you know I
thought a hot take here
I thought the doomsday bit of BVS was
actually kind of cool I thought it was a
good fight I thought it was a fun way to
bring doomsday into it I think that
Jesse Eisenberg's weird performance was
way worse than doomsday was I love it I
love bringing people together how are we
you didn't like when he put the candy in
the guy's mouth you know what I did like
that that was the one bit that I loved
and it's not it's not all bad but
there's there's so many cringing
elements about I think because one crew
gates the other you have to give them
all the credit to Natalie I think we are
all saying this is Eisenberg yeah this
is Eisenberg's doing from from day one
this it and so I think it is definitely
Jesse Eisenberg's less glue thir well he
might be drinking granny's peach tea in
the finals Jesse Eisenberg moving on out
of the Superman division Wow let's go to
the non blue MCU that rhymed okay from
Thor to Malekith the very forgettable
Malekith from Iron Man to whiplash from
Iron Man 3 the Mandarin also from Iron
Man 3 the fake Mandarin and then from
The Incredible Hulk abomination whoo
this is a hard one this is this is the
hardest January so I kind of want to
give the fake Mandarin Ben Kingsley a
pass in a weird sort of like like you
know a think piece counter nerd rage way
and that the inner got so mad at that
character that I didn't dislike much so
I kind of want to give I'm like no he's
good they try to thing but the reveal
that it was Guy Pearce with dragon
tattoos on his arms ruined it boom
that's one for Guy Pearce strong Guy
Pearce choice buff white guy with Asian
dragon tattoos come on man I'll back him
up on that that sounds great guy
Pearce's Mandarin the Fox Marvel
division ooh let's uh list this
undistinguished group Emma Frost from
x-men first class Deadpool
from x-men origins Wolverine Dark
Phoenix from x-men 3 Doctor Doom
Fantastic Four 2005 and Doctor Doom from
Fantastic Four 2015 whoo-whee you know I
did not see the most recent Fantastic
Four good for you does I suspect that
one is probably the worst but of these
ones that I've seen I think I'm gonna go
have to go with the first Ryan Reynolds
Deadpool a real poop fest that they had
to mulligan later with a whole other
movie yeah let's make the Merc with the
mouth a Merc with no man
yeah I actually think that the new
Deadpool film coming to existence might
have been caused by this terrible
Deadpool in which case I kind of want to
give it a pass because like that yeah
this was the worst part of an already
terrible movie but if it somehow got
Ryan Reynolds like unable to sleep at
night and as a result he spent like a
decade getting this the recent Deadpool
made I'm cool with that I be much more
interested in throwing it at the modern
fan the most most recent Fantastic Four
is Doctor Doom
what was his costume like what was that
he was a crash-test dummy with green
ooze coming yeah oh my god I'd switch
back to the the your Deadpool of choice
if you thought that it was more of a
punishment than a Redemption you know
I'm gonna I slept on this last night and
I'm gonna give this to the new doom it
was ridiculous
boom we are going new Doctor Doom
the faceless swarm division what an
intriguing division Galactus from 2007's
rise of the Silver Surfer parallax from
Green Lantern the Chitauri from the
Avengers and the Ultron army from
Avengers to Galactus
I think Galactus I'm gonna think we
think we all know it's Galactus sax
coming out of the gate very passionate
about this boom Galactus makes it in two
reps from two different Fantastic Four
franchises Wow
okay the wild-card division thus our
last division before we get to our final
eight check it out the wild card
division features super shredder from
TMNT 2 the secret of the great villain
shouldn't be on here okay
Hector Hammond from Green Lantern as
portrayed by Peter Sarsgaard Sharon
Stone's character from Catwoman by the
way the only one on here we just wrote
Sharon Stone's character like just the
actors name and character Deacon Frost
from Blade and Sam Jackson's octopus
from the spirit whoo
I mean the octopus is another example of
an actor who was not told know in a
movie that was not told know by a
director that was not told know that an
audience of Americans said no I think I
think the octopus just just because
honestly the in like total turd burgers
own that we're in now I got to go for
the first thing that I gravitate towards
and
just plain ridiculous club kid Deacon
Frost
uh no chance for blade you know just a
guy that sits with his weird blue
cigarettes and I'm giving this to Deacon
I agree with you the blade is a great
movie I'm gonna say what I think part of
what makes blade so great is Deacon
Frost performance if for nothing else
than for what blade kills him and then
says some mother always trying to ice
skate uphill some mother always trying
to ice skate over you
the best line in the history of movies
love Deacon Frost love super shredder uh
I don't know why you've seen the spirit
that's trained but if it is indeed one
of those one of those hammy sketch
comedy performances in an otherwise
serious movie then I agree with you I
think that is the worst kind of comic
book movie performance and I will I will
go for this
samuel l.jackson performance that I have
not seen Samuel Jackson welcome to the
mother final eight gentlemen the final
eight is set let's decide the first
matchup Mr Freeze versus electro sorry I
think you have to go electro as the
worst because I think there's still some
sort of strange
they used too much punch arm on on mr.
freeze we're like you kind of want to
look back to it an older time where
movies could be terrible and we could
all still kind of tolerate them all
right everyone in many ways electro was
in a modern film that should have known
better and didn't so I feel like
Electro's terribly off the rails at
every stage character is consistently
worse than mr. freeze that's one for
electro Jordan agreed
the Arnold Schwarzenegger thing was bad
but he's giving a campy performance in a
campy movie so he's you know acting
correctly pretty memorable I think we
all still like to say ice to see you
every now and then I still see you were
able to laugh at the Schwarzenegger
Schwarzenegger one is at least fun the
Jamie Foxx when you roll your eyes at so
yeah I gotta go Jamie Foxx that is a
that's a real garbage dump electro
beaten out a tough competitor
Schwarzenegger is mr. freeze electro
moving on whoo all right we have Sam
Jackson's octopus from the spirit versus
Galactus from 2007's rise of the Silver
Surfer Fantastic Four rise of the Silver
Surfer Joestar you know I have never
seen someone kill any of the goodwill he
had from Sin City faster than Frank
Miller trying to make the spirit and Sam
Jackson was a big part of that so I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go Sam
one for Sam Jackson sax car you know I
have a huge problem with like giant
cloud based and
interpretations of big monsters I think
that that is an easy out that's like hey
the CG guys can do this cheap and so I
have to go in that direction I have to
punish the people who make monsters into
big clouds Galactus it gets my vote oh
we are locked at one one ya gonna go
Galactus just because I saw it and it
bummed me out I can't argue with being
bummed boom
Galactus knocks off Sam Jackson ooh this
one's a doozy evil Peter Parker versus
Jesse Eisenberg's Lex Luthor uh two
garbage dumps here yes uh but I will say
at least the Peter Parker thing was done
with a sense of fun
the Jesse Eisenberg thing I think is
just bad and misguided through and
through yeah I'm gonna go Eisenberg won
for Jesse Eisenberg Joestar I can only
hate swing dancing so much so I'm gonna
go Jesse Eisenberg Jesse Eisenberg's Lex
Luthor makes it to our final four can
you believe it guy Pearce's Mandarin vs.
2015 dr. doom you know I'm just gonna go
calm I'm gonna go comic nerd purist guy
Pearce's Mandarin is further from being
docked from being the comic Mandarin
then Doctor Doom in the movie is from
being Doctor Doom in the comics although
not by much so guy Pearce's Mandarin is
worse one Oh again didn't see that bad
Fantastic Four but from everything I've
heard it's a crap pile so yeah I think I
am going to go sight unseen this bad dr.
doom that I'm sure was baby got it 1 1
we are locked at 1 1 Joe you know
sometimes when I close my eyes I still
see that terrible dr. doom so I'm I'm
gonna give this to doom boom dr. doom
our final four is set and what a
dumpster fire is electro vs. Galactus I
think I'm gonna go bad performance over
bad CGI Electro's moving on a big Spidey
fan big electro fan could have been
great and wasn't gotcha boom that's one
for electro Joestar you know as much as
I want to support Sachs's cloud hate
don't you know my vote goes to electro
electro aka max Dillon in the finals
gentlemen have there been two worst
villains over the past two years then
Jesse Eisenberg's Lex Luthor versus Toby
Kebbell 'he's dr. doom you know both of
these are the worst thing but Jesse
Eisenberg had more opportunity to do the
worst things than doom did and you know
bring the YouTube comments but I got
coach Jesse Eisenberg here and I didn't
want to I really didn't want to all
right you're voting for the PhD Jesse
Eisenberg Jordan Morris yeah you know
he's an iconic villain they boned it
could have been great Eisenberg's a
great actor uh this this should have
been amazing and it just wasn't yeah
Jesse yeah Jesse Eisenberg all right
the red capes coming gentlemen the
finals is set Jamie Foxx's electro aka
max Dillon vs Jesse Eisenberg's Lex
Luthor a match made in hell I have to
say like I've also been a surprisingly
vocal about not enjoying Batman V
Superman whatever like Lex Luthor is the
part of that film that's so bad that
this is very hard to explain why I'm
just getting it wrong like you're not
sophisticated enough to understand what
the peach tea scene is true cinematic
brilliance so yeah it is definitely the
worst thing ever and even though electro
is terrible
it is definitely yet it didn't Berg all
the way that's 104 Jesse Eisenberg you
know these are two ticky weird big swing
performances the Jesse Eisenberg the
Jesse Eisenberg one is very weird but I
do think that maybe BVS gets an unfair
amount of heat it's a pretty cool movie
with a lot to like about it and the
electro thing is just so broad uh yeah
he looks like he's a guy who the only
nerd he's ever seen he watched one
episode of Big Bang Theory
and just went crazy with it JP Jed Jamie
Foxx is a handsome man that they just
stuck glasses on and nothing else I'm
gonna have to go Jamie Foxx as electro
amazing spider-man - boom we are locked
at 1:1 Joestar you have the deciding
vote so I'm going a little meta which
one of these villains killed their
franchise more DC as we saw a comic-con
has a whole lot more movies coming oh
yeah sony was so wrecked by electro they
had to agree to work with another
corporation just to revitalize this
franchise and that's nuts to me some say
they were a hacked by North Korea
because of electro so and North Korea's
the biggest villains of all so by proxy
North Korea / electro ladies and
gentlemen we have crowned the worst
cinematic comic-book villain of all time
Jamie Foxx's electro aka max dill and
gentlemen give yourselves a round of
applause you watching at home give
yourselves a round of applause and let
us know did you agree with our choice
who did you think should have made it
out of the book the early bracket round
who is your worst comic book movie
villain of all time tell us in the
comments below
oh I got to thank this panel of awesome
dudes joestar Jordan Morris sax car
thanks for being here thank you for
watching I'm Howard Nick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye
hey screen junkies this Saturday
movie fights welcomes its most epic
guests ever Seth Rogen for an almost too
hot for the Internet episode of r-rated
movie fights be sure to come back this
Saturday at 10 a.m. Pacific to see Seth
enter the movie fights arena will he
emerge victorious tune in this weekend
to find out its movie fights like you've
never seen it before